Okay.
Uh, either on purpose or accidentally.
Donald Trump has admitted publicly for the
first time that I'm aware of that Russia helped
to get him elected.
Donald Trump admitted this in a series of
tweets this morning responding to yesterday's
Robert Muller statement about the investigation.
And I, I want your help figuring this out
because I genuinely don't know whether Donald
Trump realizes that he admitted to Russia
helping to get him elected.
Let's take a look at the tweets and go right
to the source.
Trump tweeting this morning, Russia, Russia,
Russia, that's all you heard at the beginning
of this witch hunt hoax.
And now Russia has disappeared because I had
nothing to do with Russia helping me to get
elected.
It was a crime that didn't exist.
And then Donald Trump going on to say, so
now the Dems and their partner, the fake news
media say he fought back against this phony
crime that didn't exist, this horrendous false
accusation, et Cetera, et cetera.
But again, Donald Trump is denying, not that
Russia helped him to win, but that he had
anything to do with Russia helping him to
when this is finally an admission that Russia
helped Trump, which Trump had here too, for
not admitted to.
And in fact, Trump denied it countless times.
Trump denied that Russia helped Trump denied
that Russia preferred him over Hillary.
And yet here he is admitting to it as a foregone
conclusion.
Not even arguing that Russia didn't help him
to win, simply saying he wasn't involved with
it, he didn't have anything to do with it.
Um, Trump previously said Russian interference
if it existed, had no effect on the election
results.
Trump previously said at other times there
was no interference.
And then of course, after Donald Trump says
I had nothing to do with Russia helping me
to get elected, he later backtracked.
Less than an hour later, he was walking out
to his helicopter, I believe, at the White
House, and he was asked about those tweets.
Mr President, you, you just, you seem to have
admitted that Russia did help you get elected,
but you had nothing to do with it.
And then he backtracked and said, no, no,
no.
Russia didn't actually help me to get elected.
Another hundred and 80 degree flip on the
tweet from an hour earlier would, which in
and of itself was 180 degrees, 80 degree turnaround
from his previous statements that Russia didn't
actually play a role in helping to get them
elected.
So before we didn't have Trump on record admitting
that Russia helped get him elected before
Donald Trump tweeted that he had nothing to
do with Russia helping to get them elected.
We only had the Paul Manafort stuff and the
Jeff sessions, Russia allies and the Michael
Flynn Russia fiasco and the Russian oligarch
stuff, and the money laundering for Russians
thing and the Trump tower meeting thing, and
the spilling of secrets from Israel to a Russian
spy recruiter in the Oval Office thing and
the Russia giving stuff to wikileaks to publish
and help Trump thing and the Russia.
If you're listening, get those emails and
then Russia does actually go and hack and
get Hillary's emails.
We only had all of that stuff and dozens of
other things before Donald Trump's tweets,
but now we actually have a tweet from Donald
Trump admitting that Russia helped to get
him elected, but he didn't have anything to
do with it.
One other tweet I want to mention right before
Donald Trump sent these tweets, he sent another
one just riddled with lies.
Take a look at this.
Donald Trump tweeting the greatest presidential
harassment in history after spending $40 million
over two years, two dark years.
Remember that the probe ended up making money
because of all the money it recovered from
criminals with unlimited access people, resources
and cooperation, which is of course wrong.
Donald Trump did everything possible to avoid
sitting down with Robert Mueller and ended
up providing completely bogus and meaningless
answers in writing.
Highly conflicted.
Robert Mueller would've brought charges, of
course, no evidence of Mueller being conflicted
if he had anything, but there were no charges
to bring.
And of course, Robert Mueller says he cannot
clear Donald Trump of obstruction of justice
and explains the political reasons which led
to him not charging Donald Trump.
I still think it's important to get all of
this stuff on the record, right?
Trump now has admitted in a tweet that Russia
helped him to get elected anytime from now
going forward that this is called into question.
Let's just remember, Trump has admitted it.
And this will actually, even though it's very
obvious to anybody who's been observing this
for the last two years, getting it on record
and having it to refer to May allow us to
short circuit some pointless and circular
endless arguments that the right and defenders
of Trump are deniers of reality may try to
push.
So I get it.
Trump backtracked within an hour.
Um, someone I'm sure explained to him that,
uh, the, the, the wording implicitly suggests
or says or confirms that yes, Russia helped,
but Trump didn't have anything to do with
it.
I get that he backtracked on it an hour later
in front of his helicopter.
It's still useful to get this stuff on record
as we build our case and expand the way in
which we can discuss this going forward.
So major, major admission from Donald Trump,
unclear if he even realizes he admitted it.
Uh, let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
Did Donald Trump understand when he put together
that tweet that he was admitting that Russia
helped but denied he had anything to do with
it or did he not even understand
that
that's what
he was doing?
Let me know what the